Měření kvantové superpozice je stejně náhodné jako hod mincí – ale jak daleko tuto
analogii můžeme táhnout, než se rozpadne? To zjistíme dnes v Qiskit
v učebně. Vítej v Qiskit v učebně – videosériál, kde rozebíráme základní koncepty, se kterými se
možná setkáš v kurzu spojeném s kvantovou výpočetní technikou. Každé video je doprovázeno interaktivním modulem odkazovaným v
popisu níže, takže se na to určitě podívej. Dnes mluvíme o jednom ze základních principů v srdci
kvantové teorie – superpozici. V naší každodenní zkušenosti mají předměty vždy určité vlastnosti – jejich polohu, velikost,
tvar, barvu – vše o nich je určeno a jisté, i kdyby my jako pozorovatelé to ještě neměřili. V
kvantovém světě to není nutně pravda. Kvantový objekt může být v něčem, čemu říkáme superpozice
více klasicky povolených stavů, která se při měření náhodně zhroutí do jednoho z těchto
stavů. Měření superpozičního stavu je jako hod mincí – není způsob, jak předem vědět, na které straně
přistane. Tento základní indeterminismus je nepohodlným aspektem kvantové mechaniky, s nímž měl problémy i Einstein.
Slavně o této náhodnosti řekl „Bůh nehraje v kostky" – ale jak uvidíme, Bůh ve skutečnosti v kostky hraje, nebo v
našem případě hází mincemi. A co víc, tyto mince jsou naložené. Měření kvantové superpozice může být v jistém smyslu podobné
hodu mincí, ale superpozice samotná je mnohem bohatší a složitější než klasický
pravděpodobnostní stav. Abychom to viděli, zamyslíme se nad tím, jak funguje klasická mince, a srovnáme to s naší
kvantovou mincí, kterou prozkoumáme pomocí Qiskit na IBM kvantovém počítači. Nejprve klasická mince – je to
poměrně jednoduché: hodíš mincí a padne buď lícem nebo rubem s 50% pravděpodobností každého. Principiálně bychom mohli
vypočítat, na které straně mince přistane, kdybychom znali přesné počáteční podmínky mince a přesně to, kolik
síly a točivého momentu bylo při hodu aplikováno. Ale v praxi není způsob, jak a priori vědět, na které straně
mince přistane. Proto používáme hod mincí jako kanonický příklad klasického pravděpodobnostního stavu, kde
výsledek je v podstatě náhodný. Kdybych hodil touto mincí tisíckrát a zaznamenal počet lícem a
rubem nahoru, dostal bych histogram, který vypadá přibližně takto – máme počty na ose Y
a může to být buď líc nahoru nebo rub nahoru a
histogram by ukázal, že je přibližně 500 počtů každého – s určitými statistickými
výkyvy. Podobný stav lze vytvořit pomocí qubitů na kvantovém počítači. Stejně jako hod mincí
lze qubit měřit ve dvou možných stavech – nule a jedničce. Pokud aplikujeme něco, čemu se říká Hadamard gate, na
qubit, uvede ho do rovné superpozice nuly a jedničky. Zde je
vizualizace tohoto circuit, čemuž říkáme circuit diagram. Zde horní vodič je
qubit a operace aplikované na qubit se zobrazují jako rámečky na vodičích. Hadamard gate je zobrazen tímto rámečkem
označeným H a měření je zobrazeno tímto šedým rámečkem označeným malým symbolem měření. Posílá toto
měření na klasický bit – tento vodič se dvěma linkami. Takže protože qubit je v rovné superpozici 0 a 1, když
ho změříme, bude 50% šance, že naměříme nulu, a 50% šance, že naměříme
jedničku. Tento kvantový superpozicní stav vyjadřujeme jako s = 1/
√2 |0⟩ + 1/√2 |1⟩, kde druhé mocniny každého z těchto
koeficientů – také nazývaných amplitudy – jsou pravděpodobnosti měření každého stavu. Takže v podstatě aplikace Hadamard
gate je analogií hodu mincí. A stejně jako jsme hodili mincí tisíckrát, abychom se podívali na
statistiku přistávání mince lícem nebo rubem nahoru, můžeme udělat něco podobného v Qiskit s naší kvantovou mincí.
Použijeme primitiv Qiskit nazývaný sampler, který bude opakovat circuit několikrát, aby vzorkoval statistiku
výsledného stavu. S tisícem vzorků výše uvedeného circuit máme něco, co vypadá v podstatě identicky
s histogramem klasické mince – s určitými statistickými výkyvy. Takže to je vše? Kvantové
superpozice jsou v podstatě stejné jako klasický pravděpodobnostní stav podobný hodu mincí? Ani zdaleka. Bylo by to
poměrně krátké video, kdyby to tak bylo. Abychom viděli náš první klíčový rozdíl, zkusím s klasickou mincí něco trochu jiného. Místo
toho, abych ji jednoduše nechal padnout na stůl lícem nebo rubem nahoru, hodím mincí a
chytím ji ve vzduchu mezi dlaněmi. Nyní mince není lícem nebo rubem nahoru, ale je buď hlavou doleva
nebo doprava. Logika nám říká, že i toto by mělo mít pravděpodobnost 50/50 –
buď hlavou doleva nebo doprava. Abychom měřili „hlavu vlevo nebo vpravo" na naší kvantové minci, můžeme udělat, co jsme dělali s klasickou
mincí – měřit podél jiné osy. Naše standardní měření na kvantovém počítači jsou podél svislé osy –
stejně jako obvyklé měření lícem nebo rubem nahoru klasické mince. Ale můžeme se také ptát naší kvantové mince, jestli je
hlavou doleva nebo doprava. Těmto dvěma stavům podél osy X říkáme plus nebo mínus.
K tomu použijeme primitiv Qiskit nazývaný estimator. Aby to bylo trochu složitější – namísto vrácení histogramu, jako to dělá
sampler, nám estimator místo toho dá tzv. střední hodnotu jakéhokoli observablu qubitů.
Abychom tuto střední hodnotu pochopili, řekněme, že dostaneš dolar pokaždé, když mince padne lícem nahoru, a ztratíš dolar, když
padne rubem nahoru. Střední hodnota je, kolik peněz můžeš očekávat, že vyděláš v průměru při každém hodu mincí. Protože
je stejně pravděpodobné, že dolar získáš nebo ztratíš, střední hodnota by byla nula. Stejné uvažování lze aplikovat
na qubit – když zjistíme střední hodnotu X: když aplikujeme X na stav plus, dostaneme hodnotu +1
a na stav mínus dostaneme -1. Takže kdybychom měli rozdělení 50/50, dostali bychom střední hodnotu nula. Ale nedostaneme ji –
dostaneme střední hodnotu +1, což znamená, že mince je vždy měřena jako plus podél osy X. To by bylo jako hodit
mincí, chytit ji a zaručit, že hlava bude vždy otočena doprava. To je proto, že
superpozice není jen rozdělení pravděpodobnosti. Vzpomeň, jak vyjadřujeme kvantový
stav – s je rovno C0 krát stav 0 plus C1
krát stav 1, kde každý z těchto koeficientů je komplexní – což znamená, že
WEBVTT
mají reálnou i imaginární část. Říkají nám tedy o pravděpodobnostech, ale také skrývají jinou veličinu nazvanou
fáze. Koeficient C lze zapsat
takto – kde C se rovná magnitudě krát tato fáze, přičemž toto phi je
fáze. Je to trochu jako fáze vlny nebo poloha hřebenů a prohlubní vlny. Pokud jsou dvě vlny ve fázi
s sebou navzájem – jejich hřebeny a prohlubně jsou zarovnány – pak se zkombinují do vlny dvakrát
tak vysoké. Tomu říkáme konstruktivní interference. Pokud jsou mimo fázi,
interferují destruktivně a navzájem se úplně ruší.
Abychom viděli, jak může fáze způsobit interferenci v naší kvantové minci, zkusme aplikovat Hadamard dvakrát místo jednou. Nyní klasicky
by to nedávalo žádný smysl – pokud je aplikace Hadamard ekvivalentní hodu mincí, nemůžeš hodit mincí, která již letí. Ale uvidíme, co se
stane kvantově mechanicky. Aplikujeme tedy Hadamard dvakrát a vzorkujeme výsledný stav.
Úžasně – již nemáme pravděpodobnost 50/50. Výsledný histogram ukazuje, že v každém případě naměříme
qubit ve stavu nula. Takže druhý Hadamard vrátil qubit do stavu nula, kde jsme začali. Je to trochu
obtížné na první pohled vidět, ale díky interferenci kvantového stavu. Místo toho, aby k interferenci docházelo
v reálném prostoru jako u skutečné vlny, k interferenci dochází v abstraktním informačním prostoru qubitů.
Druhý Hadamard gate způsobil, že nulová část superpozice interferovala konstruktivně, zatímco jednová část
superpozice interferovala destruktivně a zmizela. Prozkoumejme dál. Fázi můžeme změnit pomocí
něčeho, čemu se říká phase gate. Nyní tedy aplikujme Hadamard k vytvoření superpozice, aplikujeme fázový posun Pi radiánů
a pak aplikujme druhý Hadamard. Nyní se zdá, že naše kvantová mince vždy vychází ve stavu jedna.
Fázový posun Pi vyměnil části superpozičního stavu, které byly ve fázi a mimo fázi s sebou navzájem,
takže výsledný stav je jedna místo nuly. Bylo by to jako hodit mincí a zatímco je ve vzduchu, být schopen
nějak aplikovat operaci, která by zaručila, že vždy přistane lícem nebo vždy rubem – v závislosti na
operaci. V klasickém případě nemožné, ale ne v kvantovém případě. Co jsme se naučili z těchto experimentů,
je, že tato nová schopnost kvantové mince je způsobena její fází – vlastností, kterou kvantová superpozice má, ale klasické
rozdělení pravděpodobnosti nemá. Takže obvyklý hod mincí není ve skutečnosti tak skvělou analogií pro
superpozici, protože nic neříká o této fázi. Myslím, že to můžeme dělat lépe. Udělám ještě jeden
experiment s naší mincí. Mám minci ležící na stole lícem nahoru. Abych ji dala rubem dolů, mohu ji jednoduše překlopit. To je
výpočetní ekvivalent NOT gate. Řekněme, že chceme zkonstruovat operaci, která by po dvojím aplikování byla
ekvivalentní tomuto NOT gate. Tuto operaci lze nazvat odmocninou NOT. Přemýšlej tedy o tom, co fyzicky děláme,
když aplikujeme NOT gate – otáčíme ji o 180° například kolem osy X. Takže kdybychom minci
otočili jen o 90° kolem osy X, dostali bychom odmocninu NOT. Aplikujme tedy
naši odmocninu NOT a mince jen stojí na hraně. Nyní se ptáme: je lícem nebo rubem nahoru? No,
jasně, ani jedno. Ale mohli bychom přidat krok k procesu měření, abychom ji přinutili být lícem nebo rubem nahoru. Nyní
mince padne na stranu lícem nebo rubem nahoru se stejnou pravděpodobností. Opět bychom principiálně mohli předpovědět,
na kterou stranu padne, ale v praxi je to dostatečně obtížné na předpovídání, aby to bylo v podstatě náhodné. Pokud chci
měřit, zda je hlavou vlevo nebo vpravo, mohu ji zmáčknout v tom směru podobným způsobem a opět nám to dá
pravděpodobnost 50/50 vlevo a vpravo. Ale v tomto rozměru – hlava vpřed nebo vzad –
hlava již směřuje vpřed, takže 100 % času ji naměříme jako hlavu vpřed. Zatímco tedy měření X a Z
yielded náhodné výsledky, měření Y vždy yielded stejný výsledek. Pokud se vrátíme zpět k
experimentu s kvantovým hodem mincí z předchozí části, toto připomíná to, jak se kvantová mince chovala po
aplikaci Hadamard – qubit byl měřen jako nula nebo 1 s pravděpodobností 50/50 ve směru Z, ale
vždy stav plus a nikdy stav mínus podél X. To naznačuje, že mince stojící klidně na hraně
je možná lepším způsobem, jak vizualizovat superpozicní stav qubitů, než mince divoce letící vzduchem.
Aplikujme gate odmocniny NOT na naší kvantové minci v Qiskit – máme tento jednoduchý
circuit. Pak použijeme estimator ke kontrole střední hodnoty tří observabilů X, Y a Z – což je trochu
jako zhroutit naši minci podél každého ze tří rozměrů, jak jsem právě ukázala. Střední hodnoty jsou tedy 0,
-1 a 0 pro X, Y a Z. To je stejný výsledek, jaký jsme
dostali pro rotaci odmocninou NOT aplikovanou na klasickou minci. Existuje ve skutečnosti přesná analogie mezi mincí
a stavem qubitů. Nyní si můžeme stav qubitů vizualizovat jako vektor ukazující ve směru hlav
na minci – normálový k povrchu mince. Takže hlava nahoru neboli stav nula
na kvantové minci je ekvivalentní vektoru ukazujícímu přímo nahoru. Hlava dolů neboli jedna ukazuje přímo dolů a jakákoli
rovná superpozice 0 a 1 ukazuje horizontálně. Fáze kvantového stavu určuje přesný horizontální
směr, na který ukazuje – například zda ukazuje podél osy X nebo podél osy Y nebo někam
mezi nimi. Tento vektor je znám jako Blochův vektor a plně a jedinečně určuje kvantový stav jednoho
qubitů. Nyní si můžeme znovu představit každý gate, který jsme v tomto videu viděli, jako rotaci nebo sérii rotací na
minci – nebo ekvivalentně na Blochově vektoru. NOT gate je rotace o
180° kolem osy X – když je aplikována na náš stav nula nebo hlava nahoru, překlápí se do
stavu dolů neboli 1. Odmocnina NOT je jen 90° kolem téže osy X – počínaje
od stavu hlava nahoru toto rotuje na hlavu vpřed. Phase gate je rotace o phi kolem osy Z – protože
hlava nahoru je zarovnána s osou Z, to s mincí nic nedělá. Hadamard gate je o trochu trickier – my
jsme ho původně přirovnali k hodu mincí, čímž se mince ve vzduchu nekontrolovatelně točí, ale Hadamard je vlastně
WEBVTT
řízená deterministická rotace mince – stejně jako všechny ostatní gate. Hadamard se provede rotací o 90°
kolem osy Y a pak o 180° kolem osy X. Takže aplikováno na stav hlava nahoru
skončí jako hlava vpravo. Takže na kvantovém superpozicním stavu nebo na žádné ze standardních operací,
které na qubitů provádíme, není nic náhodného. Každá operace je deterministická a reverzibilní. Jedinou
dobou, kdy náhodnost vstupuje do hry, je, když se rozhodneme měřit kvantový stav. Zda je kvantový stav vůbec v
superpozici, je skutečně jen věcí pozorovatele. Jak jsi pravděpodobně narazil, jsme svobodni zvolit si náš
souřadnicový systém – X, Y a Z mohou ukazovat podél jakýchkoli tří kolmých směrů. Takže
pokud máme superpozici 0 a 1 v jednom souřadnicovém systému, můžeme definovat nový souřadnicový systém nebo novou tzv.
bázi, ve které stav ukazuje čistě ve směru plus Z – a tedy není v superpozičním stavu.
Když tedy říkáme, že qubit je v superpozici, musíme také definovat náš souřadnicový systém nebo
bázi. Možná toto video opustíš s dojmem, že jsme právě odstranili veškeré tajemství z kvantové mechaniky.
Koneckonců jeden z údajně nejpodivnějších aspektů – superpozicní stav qubitů – je ve skutečnosti stejně jednoduchý jako
trojrozměrný vektor. Ale mějte na paměti, že mince je stále jen analogie a dokonce i Blochův vektor je
pouze vizualizačním nástrojem. Pro výpočet pravděpodobností výsledků měření nemůžeme říct, co kvantový
stav skutečně dělá před měřením, protože ověření toho vyžaduje měření. O tomto
dilematu – jaká je skutečná povaha kvantového stavu – a o tom, jak kvantový jev provázání může pomoci nám
toto objasnit, budeme diskutovat v jiné epizodě Qiskit v učebně – věnované Bellově nerovnosti. Mezitím ale, pokud
si chceš hrát s kvantovými mincemi a sám se dozvědět o superpozicních stavech qubitů a o tom, jak je
ovládat, přejdi do modulu kvantové mince odkazovaného v popisu. Díky za sledování a uvidíme se příště.